was the radon Trump's personal attorney
just a proxy move by Muller in his
fishing expedition that's the focus of
tonight's angle do you hear that drip
drip drip sound well those are the
nonstop leaks coming from the offices of
the US Attorney for the Southern
District of New York which on Monday as
we know executed that raid on the home
the work and the temporary residence of
trumps lawyer Michael Cohen from unnamed
sources with knowledge of the
investigation we learned that the search
focused on documents related to porn
star stormy Daniels and that potential
crimes may include bank and wire fraud
along with campaign finance violations
now yesterday there were more leaks that
investigators were scouring for
information related to and I kid you not
the Access Hollywood tapes and a new
report today in The New Yorker alleging
possible payments to a Trump Tower
doorman and others during the campaign
bottom line right now as things are
Russian collusion seems to be a faint
memory and after all the hype about that
Trump Tower meeting with Don jr. and
that Russian attorney after all the hide
the ball tactics that the DOJ used
applying for that FISA warrant and you
think about it after all the speculation
about Trump's relationship with Russia
Muller has come up with goose eggs now
team Trump is properly worried that
Muller is just using the Southern
District of New York as a proxy to do
their dirty work
in other words have the New York agents
vacuumed up a whole bunch of stuff and
Cohen's files on the president's
personal business deals again arguably
outside the scope of the special
counsels jurisdiction and then shoot it
back over to us if it's helpful if
helpful to our cause and going after the
president that way Muller gets credit
for initially going to rod Rosenstein
the Deputy Attorney General with the
information in the first place what do
you think we should do with this rod
then he gets none of the downside by
being the guy who
execute that search warrant against the
president's personal attorney never
happened in the history of the country
before now remember last summer
President Trump said that the effort any
effort by the feds to look into his
personal finances is hmm I was looking
at your finances your family's finances
related to Russia is that what the
breach what is actual now the whole
process is totally out of control and
this is why the Special Counsel statute
in my mind is unconstitutional you think
about it this way Muller's office
resides within the executive branch and
that means if he wants to if it's
politically appropriate for him to do so
as the head of the executive branch the
president should be able to fire him but
if Muller did if Miller did get fired by
Trump for whatever reason all hell would
break loose
firing rod Rosenstein or Robert Muller
would provoke a constitutional firestorm
there's no question that if President
Trump fired mullah Rosenstein or even
sessions he would set in motion a
constitutional crisis this is a new
level of crazy for Trump a new level of
being out of control and they I think
for the first time are really petrified
he is going to take that step and then
they're gonna be in the midst of a
constitutional crisis are you tired of
the pundit echo chamber they just keep
repeating themselves each other day
after day after day there's no original
thought you know what a constitutional
crisis is my friends when an unelected
in largely unaccountable band of
hyper-partisan attorneys loyal to the
previous president and maybe even
Hillary Clinton they're able to spend
millions of your tax dollars in search
of a crime merely to undo the results of
a presidential election that's the thing
that should worry us and that's the
angle